so simple when you get the life is
really short and you felt that before
but either by you were threatened or you
have that real Essence in you that says
life is short have reverence for it live
it that's a really big thing I got that
at 19 and I learned specifically that if
we have a moment of cognition before the
end of our life we tend to ask questions
to evaluate if we're happy so if I have
any impact in the world it's going to
come from that experience where I
learned that the ultimate lesson is
determine what the questions you're
going to ask at the end of your life are
going to be so that you would know if
you were happy with your life and then
live each day intentionally so you're
happy with the answers at the end the
questions I had were did I live which I
hadn't I've been living my life I've
been thinking about taking my life did I
love no my heart was broken and I put up
all these walls to keep out other people
and I learned that I would ask did I
matter 22 years ago on a dark Caribbean
night I'm standing on the crumpled bit
of a car bleeding out my friend he's
screaming at top of his lungs he's
bleeding we don't freaking live I'm
standing on this car looking down all
this blood and I'm in Terror and I just
remember looking down the hood thinking
did I even matter and I hated the answer
at that time in life I didn't know about
impact Theory did I matter I didn't
think I did but the good news is I'm a
good learner and I felt like I got a
second chance from God that night and I
learned that it was really important for
me to figure out how do I live and how
do I love and how do I matter in such a
way that if I face my death again I'll
know I've earned the second chance I
just want people to know your questions
Man live intentionally and earn the life
that you've been given because This
Moment's a blessing so earn this moment
and live intentionally
the difference between a great day and a
mediocre one
is your intention
how did you decide to show up today most
people have no intention most people you
wake up you check your phone you're
falling into other people's emergencies
other people's demands and your time
what everybody else wants for you to do
today right everybody's got an agenda
everybody's got an opinion on what you
should do with your life you open your
phone there's all sorts of other
people's emergencies for what you should
be doing right their emergencies become
your priorities because you don't have
intention in the day where when you flip
it when you start to say no I am going
to take control of my day take control
of my life and start to live with
intention everything starts to shift
the most important part of my morning
routine is intention
every day here's what I do I wake up I
am tired I am I'm groggy I'm I'm like
forget what day it is forget what year
it is forget who I am I wake up I got
stuff in my eyes I got lines on my face
so you know I'm just I'm groggy I don't
wake up excited and like yeah my god
let's go we're filming content today you
know I have to remind myself of what I'm
doing and
as I walk to the bathroom
I'll usually put on a song and in the
morning usually I have some oldies
playing because it just makes me happy
so I'll put on some oldie and I'm going
to the bathroom and I find myself just
starting to dance a little bit which is
great because the motion starts to
change things if you put on songs that
make you happy that make you moving it's
going to start to shift your entire day
and music is the fastest way to change
your state and then as I'm going to the
bathroom might be too much detail I'll
then look at my calendar
I'll look at my calendar
and I'll say how do I want to show up
what's my intention for today
what is my intention for today for how I
want to show up for whatever's in my
calendar today
and today is a Tuesday Tuesdays are when
I make videos I don't know when this is
going to be released but
what's my intention this morning I look
at my calendar I see I've got a bunch of
YouTube videos that I'm going to make
today I'm going to go with Nina and
she's going to run some errands and I'm
going to film from the car
and I want to make content that matters
I want to make something that matters
today I want to I want to make something
that's going to inspire somebody today I
want to make a video that touches
somebody's life today I want to make
potentially the best video I've ever
made today
I want to speak some truth into the
camera I want to touch somebody's soul
in the content that I'm making that's my
goal for today
you think that changes how you show up
right it's like as opposed to just oh
I'm gonna make some videos today okay
cool cool let's go do that
that process doesn't have to take an
hour in the morning
right that process is while I'm going to
the bathroom right it takes takes a
minute
not very long
but it shifts everything
because it it changes
how you show up for the entire day
I've also got on my on the background of
my cell phone the background says
remember your intention
as a trigger so anytime I load my phone
I can see that between videos and I
press stop and I'm loading the next one
I see the background of my phone again
remember your intention yeah what was my
intention this morning because even if
you set it up in the morning it doesn't
mean the whole day is going to be
amazing something's going to throw you
off
you come back to your intention what was
my intention today
and it works for being
your business goals it works to
accomplishing your business goals it
works for your personal goals on
Saturdays is my fun day and I'll usually
plan something to do with my wife Nina
and maybe it's a hiking trip maybe it's
a we're going to go out and try out a
new restaurant like it's fun it's not
it's not chores it's not tasks it's not
business it's just something for us to
do so the intentions showing up is
different what's my intention today well
my attention is to be the best husband I
can be what does that mean like not just
words but you're trying to feel it what
does that mean I want to have a great
day with Nina I want to make her smile
today I want to make her laugh today I
want to be present today I want to not
be frustrated by some little thing that
happens I don't want to be sucked into
anything on the work side I don't want
to be daydreaming about business I want
to be thinking about
my life with Nina I want to be
daydreaming about where we're going to
go together as a couple right and the
words will change
but even now that just saying that puts
me into a different mindset I got to
bring it back I want to make killer
videos for you guys
we just don't have intention
you know we know we want more you know
you want more you know you want more to
life you know you want to accomplish
more you know you want to be more you
know you want to serve more
and that's a great feeling but we don't
hold on to it long enough to actually do
something with
and we'll usually think of that I want
to do more I know I'm capable of more
and use it to beat ourselves up to say
well look I did I didn't do it I should
have done it last week I should have
started last year I was too afraid to do
it we just beat ourselves up and blame
ourselves for not doing more as opposed
to using that intentionality to then
create a better life for ourselves today
and it starts with today it starts with
today like right now the rest of today
can be different if he chose to with
intention show up
so how do we do it how do we how do how
do we do it today how do we do it
ongoing because if you woke up with
intention for the next year
hold a cat is your life look different
step number one
is create the environment of
intentionality and why that matters is
because it allows it to happen on on
Auto on repeat automatically without you
having to think about it because as soon
as you move it to conscious does that
does that step does that barrier does
that block where when it's unconscious
and automatic you're much more likely to
do it so
uh the environment right so my office if
you see my office I got the pictures on
the wall they all mean something to me I
walked past in the morning I walk past
my mannequin uh of of I have a mannequin
in my office or on the way to the office
of of me wearing the hoodie because
superheroes have mannequins of people
wearing their outfits and it it it fires
me up it gets me going I have the music
right put music for how you want to feel
not for how you currently are feeling if
I put music for how I currently was
feeling in the morning and I'm just
tired and just waking up it'd probably
be some slow meditative calm birds
chirping
um waterfall kind of stuff which which
there's nothing wrong with that but it's
not how I if I ask myself how do I want
to start my day it's not with birds
chirping and waterfalls it's with
something that gets me moving because
what I'm missing the most is fun I'm not
feeling fun and energetic in the morning
and so I need that but when I put on the
lion sleeps tonight or when I put on
runarounds two or I put on a
respect you know Aretha Franklin when I
put on you know I need these oldies
I just start moving I start dancing
start singing at the top of my lungs and
that gets me going in the morning right
so the more you can have these habits
and these triggers in the morning to get
you set up
so that when you're looking at the
intention of the day
you're already in the right frame of
mind okay because if you don't have the
right mindset going in no matter what
your intention becomes it's really hard
to get it actually firing right because
you can tell yourself I want to have a
great day but if all you're thinking
about is how slow everything is and how
crappy your life is how you're not
further ahead and and how tired you are
you could say the words but it won't
land as strongly so the the environment
really matters step two is you have to
look at your calendar and see what's
ahead and come into it with intention
how do you want to show up for all the
things that are in your life today
what's on your calendar and schedule
things in right like create a calendar
that maps to your ambition your calendar
should be a macro reflection
of your intention your calendar is an
intentional life
what's in your calendar should be a
reflection of what you want out of your
life
so look at your calendar this is a great
weekly exercise to do look at your
calendar
and then see what in your life what in
what in those spots actually will let
you live the life that you want so you
say you want to be a YouTuber you say
you want to be an entrepreneur say you
want to be a great husband or wife you
say you want great show me in your
calendar where you have dedicated time
to make that intention happen because if
it's just a hope and it's never
scheduled in guess what it never happens
I'm filming content today on a Tuesday
because it's in my calendar because
that's part of an intentional life for
me where if I waited to get inspired to
do something I would make not a lot of
content
right
most of your goals are not in your
calendar and so they never get done
there's a tweetable most your goals are
not in your calendar so it never gets
done
so intentional life is putting things in
your calendar
an intentional day is in reminding
yourself in the morning of what you want
to do is how you show up so when I'm
showing up to make videos I already
explained the process that I go through
but then at night when I'm going to have
time with Nina it's different right the
the I'm not thinking about YouTube
videos anymore I'm thinking about my
time with Nina so an intentional life in
your calendar and in the morning an
intentional day just look at your
calendar and say here's what I need to
do today here's how I need to show up
because again if you plan your week on a
Sunday and planned it all out looks
great
you're going to wake up on a Wednesday
and then forget why you set that as your
goal
follow up with the same intentionality
anymore so the morning reset for
intentionality matters and then step
three is triggers so Step One is having
the environment and the routine step two
is planning out intentionality in your
life which is your calendar and on a
daily basis when you wake up and then
step three is the triggers to bring you
back when you need to so my biggest
Triggers on my cell phone my biggest
trigger is
remember your intention
so that anytime I check my phone I see
that as a reminder to myself of the
person that I said I was going to be
today
the other thing that really helped make
a big shift in my day-to-day life is I
schedule things in 25 minute increments
so I'm doing interviews I'm doing calls
I'm doing
whatever's in my calendar is in 25 or 55
minute increments before I go to the
next thing I have a five minute buffer
before going into the next thing so if
I'm doing interviews Thursday is my
interview day boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom 25 minutes back to
back to back to back to back to back the
occasional 55 minutes before the next
thing and I would do it initially just
as a buffer for timing so in case
something went over in case I had to
figure out some tech gear or because I
had to go to the washroom or whatever I
had a five minute break in between as a
buffer
but
the happy accident that came as a result
of it is I use it as a little
intentionality break for the next thing
so yesterday when I'm mentoring my team
if I'm talking to
Jeremy for 55 minutes and then I have
Alex coming up next that five minute
break in the morning it's going to be
how do I want to show up for my team
it's mentoring day I want to show up I
want to be present I want to guide them
I want to help them grow and learn and
be inspired I want to be the best leader
I can be I want them to come away from
today inspired motivated ready for
action fill them with courage and belief
right that's the morning
that sets the tone for the whole day
but in the break between Jeremy and Alex
that five minutes
I'll use a minute or two of it to set
the intention for the next one I just
came from Jeremy I'm going to Alex how
do I want to show up for Alex and I may
just be repeating the same thing that I
came up with this morning or there might
be some Nuance that would be something
different there might be something
unique about Alex that I want to remind
myself of before going into that call
with him
so the daily
reminders of the intention the daily
triggers
one is a cell phone background remember
your intention
and two is having the break the five
minute break between switching tasks to
set myself up for the next task I
remember why I'm doing that specific one
the intention matters
you know again we wake up and
it's so easy to fall into somebody
else's plan for us it's so easy to look
at our texts or look at our emails or
look at social media and feel like we're
already behind and we already owe so
many other people in our lives our time
and we don't control our day
and you have to put up
some walls
around where you're spending your time
and you have to start your day with
intentionality to say this is the life
that I want
and I'm doing the activities that move
me towards my goals
and the more that I'm intentional the
more that I am present
the more I will actually start to
accomplish those things
you have so much greatness in you you
have so much heart and so much care and
so much soul and so much of a desire to
do good and serve and help
and yet for some reason at the end of
the week it just didn't happen this week
again and it didn't happen again this
week again
the difference is creating an
intentional life for yourself and then
reminding yourself daily and throughout
the day
of what that intention is
you don't need any more money or any
more support or anything else beyond
what you already have you have
everything you need to win
the only difference between now and
where you could be in a year
is how much are you going to show up
with intentionality every day to move
closer to your goals
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
empowerment means we give people the
decision-making Authority and the trust
to be able to work towards this Vision
to allow them the autonomy the strength
the input to equip them with the
knowledge the skills the abilities the
Technologies the tools the training to
allow them to succeed as they march with
us to achieving something extraordinary
and phenomenal that's vital that's what
empowerment is about
and a lot of leaders who come in with
the big Vision they get everyone excited
you know they they seem like they they
want everybody involved and they do a
great job of standing for it but they
don't equip their teams to kick some
butt
they never get to that place of real
stride of real momentum and that happens
all the time training other people and
equipping them with everything they need
to succeed has to be a vital practice of
every great leader and again it doesn't
happen just once that's a huge failure
in the Working World especially in
Corporate America great leaders come in
they nail the vision they get people
around it they stand for something but
they only Empower people at the
beginning they give some training and
then they just disappear training has to
be consistent coaching has to be
consistent equipping people to deal with
the new challenges the new tools new
technologies the new competitive
realities that's vital we have to have
that in place research study and
psychology found out that both second
person and third person makes you more
it makes yourself talk more powerful so
if you're gonna do affirmations you
wouldn't just say I want to do this I
want to do this you want to do what we
call in the book self-coaching where you
would say you know in my case yeah
Brendan it's important you do a good job
here today because you usually don't do
interviews and you really love Marie and
you want to do a good job for her and
her people and this is a book you worked
on for three years and it's important it
does well and Brendan don't forget
you're so lucky you get to do this
brother so just enjoy the process you're
so lucky Brendan
that's a different level of going I'm
lucky I'm lucky right it is I'm Brendan
yes yes another one another one I do
everyone in the shower yeah assuming I
take a shower but every morning in the
shower we all don't every day not every
morning no we do know this doesn't
happen it does nothing it doesn't happen
I told you like 24 hours ago I was
staying in a barn in the woods at a
friend's house yeah
um but the second thing I asked myself
in the in the shower every morning is
what might happen today that could trip
me up
and how are you going to bring your best
self to that Brendan
I say that every morning in the shower
to myself and it just helps me
anticipate you know something's going to
go wrong during the day absolutely and
if I already know everything like like
this morning's was okay you're in I
think what we would I think I'm yes
North Manhattan where I'm staying would
you call it North you're Uptown I'm
uptown and you're coming to
um let's just call it downtown okay so
I'm like okay that's going to be 45
minutes it's a hot summer day yes I I'm
gonna get hot and I know when I'm hot
sometimes I get impatient yes and I get
stressed and I don't want to feel that
so just pay attention to how you're
feeling on your way down to the
interview with Marie Brendan and really
just engage pay attention be present
with New York and really enjoy that
you're here I know that sounds
completely crazy but every High
performing athlete does it every
salesperson does it I mean a high level
every person I interviewed who are at
what we call the top 15 of all high
performers outside of teaching people to
bring the joy in my life I teach people
to honor the struggle honor the
difficulty when we honor the struggle
and said I hate the struggle
we can really achieve extraordinary
things because our mindset's in the
right place it except like as soon as
you want to struggle you accept that oh
of course there should be struggle here
I should I should honor this process
when you go to the gym to work out you
like honor that this is going to be hard
and honor that process of getting better
and the more that you bring honor to it
the more your psyche builds with
strength and you get a little bit of
that esteem back
because you see yourself engaging
something versus avoiding it and running
away
you see yourself connecting with
something and giving it reverence
like like I have reverence for the
difficulties of Life they may be better
so I don't want a friction free life I'm
not interested in it you know the the
the I I like to say sometimes that you
know the journey to Greatness Begins the
moment that our you know deep desires
for comfort and ease
are overpowered by our desires to
connect and contribute what is that
habit that you take on on a daily or
monthly basis with Howard with Clarity
what do you think about you're like
every morning what am I clear about or
yeah you know how do you apply that
habit to your life I've played a couple
ways first for me every situation I go
into I'm consistently asking like what
what's the feeling I want to have here
if you ever see me Teach it's often I
would say bring the joy
so I have joy triggers that I've set up
in my mind that makes me more
intentional about things so for example
I have a door frame trigger whenever I
walk through a door I say bring the joy
so when I walk through that door right
there it's like bring the joy into this
room
it's just it's just a mental trigger
that I've set up for myself every
morning in the shower I ask myself three
questions and not that I shower every
morning
the first question I say what can I be
excited about today
so it forces me to be clear about what's
going to draw Joy enthusiasm from me
number two I say what might trip me up
today
because usually I know what's going on
in the day I'm like what what might mess
me up what might where I might not
perform well what might bother me and
number three I say what can I do to
surprise somebody today to give a gift
of appreciation or acknowledgment today
and so I think through that in the
morning so I think that helps me begin
my day pretty clear then when I sit down
before I do work I literally look at my
calendar of the day this morning
and I look at whatever's going on the
day and I think about it for 20 minutes
it's one of my 20 minute routines in the
morning I literally
think about my calendar for 20 minutes a
day
and people think that's crazy but what
I'm thinking through when I'm looking to
count I'm like okay I'm gonna have that
call what do I want to have it on that
call
you know what's my intention for that
call what's my goal for that call what's
the feeling for that call how do I want
to end that call you know I'm gonna have
that time with Lewis like how do I want
to be there and and how can I make sure
I enjoy it because it's a big deal you
know I love your show I want to do a
good job I want to share something good
for the people even though I have no
idea what you're going to ask I want to
be present for that and and make sure I
I'm I'm really there even though maybe I
have a head cold today you know it's
like that it's like just thinking
through it I think that helps me
it keeps me asking questions every
Sunday I do a life Arenas assessment
that just means I think there's 10 areas
of our life and I score myself in them
and this is about my 11th year of doing
this wow so each area of my life you
know from from emotional quality to
happiness to relationships to time to
hobby
Etc I just give myself a score of one to
ten
and one means I suck and I I was
horrible in the previous week on that 10
news I did a good job
and I ask how can I do better it's my
Sunday routine yeah and it just keeps me
clear and it's not like I don't
sometimes like everyone else you know
wonder what's going on or what I'm doing
but those habits those were my habits
you have to establish your own for
seeking Clarity but when you have them
you weaponize your life transitions take
place in the chapter of generate energy
and also maybe it's in productivity too
uh and it has this Converse it's just a
conversation that
if you're go go go go go all the time
you're depleting energy all day and you
don't know it and lots of people think
to get more energy or more productive
they have to radically change their life
I'd better work out an extra 60 Minutes
in the morning it's like actually let me
teach you the Mastery of managing
transitions when you go from one
activity to another I want to teach you
the simple thing and that is release
tension set intention
very simple let me give you an example
because it really helps if you're doing
email
and you know that takes one part of your
your psyche and brain to do a lot of
email and now you're gonna go create
that keynote or that PowerPoint
presentation that you want to be flowing
and visual and beautiful very different
things what most people do is they'll do
their email and then they'll work a
little on the presentation then the
notification will come over here and
they'll go back to the email and then
they're multitasking yes and they're
wrecking not only their measurable
creativity but their long-term
performance and so what you have to do
is when you finish email stop it okay
maybe go get some water come back or
whatever even if you don't all I want to
do push away from your chair for a
minute close your eyes
repeat the word release
with the goal of releasing tension in
your body
and repeat the word Release Yourself
several times over and over like a
mantra okay just repeat it could be 60
seconds it can be one minute can be two
minutes whatever you want to do
just do it until you feel like your body
and your mind release a little bit
then before you open your eyes set an
intention say okay
Brendan you're going to work on this
keynote now your intention is to make
something that grabs them right at the
beginning and then make it really move
fast and make it make it Visual and make
sure that it builds emotionally
throughout the thing so when you make a
call to action at the end bam
and now open my eyes Network on
presentation I'm clean and free from the
previous activity yes and people will
feel an unbelievable amount of energetic
just power come back from there I
interviewed or I've worked with a a
major founder in the startup Silicon
Valley World flew me down at 3am and uh
I guess it was around after midnight uh
private jet it was it's crazy he was
having a lot of trouble just exhausted
literally depleted
um you know this person's incredibly
well valued in this company lots of
employees everyone knows who the person
would be
but miserable just go go go go go go and
I said well let's go and one of his
major things was he was wrecking his
relationship with his wife and his
children
because not because he was maybe just
overworking he would just carry a lot of
the work in his house yep so when I say
I said I want you to pull up to your
house after the day of working don't get
out of the car
pull the pull up the house
Just Close Your Eyes repeat the Mantra
released yourself maybe five minutes
and then before we open your eyes set
the intention how do you want to be with
your wife when you enter the house
what kind of dad you want to be to your
daughter
just set that intention
open up your eyes now go in as a
different man
and it changed his life his email to me
is in the I read it it's fantastic it
just works that means just release
tension yep set intention it's just your
transitions are where most people's
bleeding out their energy and they don't
know and if we can just get you four or
five times of transition really well
throughout the day you finish your day
like I feel amazing yes and we didn't we
didn't caffeinate you we didn't do
anything we just changed how you
approach your work get up in the morning
I drink 20 ounces of water
I do 20 minutes of Mobility movement and
stretching every morning then I read for
20 minutes something positive for me
it's almost always a self-help book or a
leadership book almost always sometimes
a business but almost always self-help
and Leadership read that book then I go
and I sit down
with my high performance planner
my green tea I fill out the day
right I look at the blocks of time that
are already scheduled
and then what I use is my second
visualization which is I look at the
major blocks of time that have been
scheduled just like this this morning
and I close my eyes and I think how do I
do that thing with excellence
what would make that thing special
so this morning before I got here when I
thought about this because there's my
high performance planner impact Theory
Tom bail you oh yes three exclamation
points literally so I looked at the
schedule I closed my eyes and I thought
okay
what do I want to communicate on Tom's
show how do I want that to feel what do
I want to communicate so I literally
closed my eyes and I visualize those
blocks of time
and how would I do them well
that's a superpower most people write
their day out and they just go about the
day and then they Sometimes they come
back to the plan they go oh my god I
didn't even do it because I sit there
and I think about
how do I do that well
that's a game changer what does that
rebuilding process look like for
somebody who's trapped in depression and
Suicidal Thoughts yeah
um
I've been there a lot
in my life especially
before my car accident my teenage years
then the first woman I ever loved we had
a big breakup and that breakup sent me
down in depression and suicidal planning
and uh
it's tough to dispense advice to people
other than get help and I'll share why
because that time in my life I had so
many people coming up to me
you know my friends would come into my
dorm room let's go do something and you
just they're just the hope is lost
and what people I think make the mistake
of trying to do is hype people up
everything's gonna be okay you're gonna
be great
and what people need who are suicidal is
serious psychological intervention they
need to seek support and help and
outside of that when they do get that
support the first thing a great
therapist is going to do outside of the
emotional reflection work of why are you
here and what has caused this sort of
pattern for you they're going to get you
starting to get some momentum
the most important thing is when you are
super down
outside of finding that emotional
reasoning for where you are is to start
getting momentum because with momentum
comes hope with momentum comes
motivation with momentum comes uh you
know that feeling that there's a reason
for tomorrow and so it's as simple as
just saying okay what are three things
I'm going to do today
and I don't mean that like a lot of
personal development guys would say like
what are your three big goals for the
day I'm like dude sometimes that first
goal is shh I'm gonna shower today
I'm really in shower today
uh I'm gonna walk to the library
and come home
and that's all they got
like literally that's all they got
and you gotta honor that struggle when
you're in that place like know that
where you're at it is okay that you're
there and now you're gonna need help and
now you're gonna have to set up some
daily practices just every day win a
little bit not like win your dreams not
like Crush through goals not like being
badass not like no
momentum man next habit is high
performers develop influence
more than those around them it's not
because they're cool it's not I mean
look at me I'm not getting ahead on my
cool Factor here I just got these new
Nikes I walk in the store it's like
what's your newest shoe they're like
these ones I'm like I need that and
they're like wow I'm like because Lewis
has sneaks man I I wear suits or like
I'm either on stage in a suit or or at
my you know Studio kind of like you know
kind of formal too sure sure um I was
like man I gotta get some sneakers I
said give me your newest sneak so I'm
not getting ahead on the cool I don't
develop influence because I'm cool it's
not your personality that gives you
influence it's how you treat other
people and specifically the way that
people high performers gain influence is
is this way too much
get it
here's how you develop influence
if you really want high level of
influence
obviously you got to do all the basics
treat people nice be kind and in the
book what I do is with each habit I say
here's the basics but then I go here's
what the needle mover practices are
the highest performing influencers what
they're doing often they don't know
they're doing it by the way
the first thing they're doing is they're
teaching people how to think
a lot of your show
gained influence I really believe
because you're really good at teaching
people how to think thank you you're
shaping their mindset
but High performers are really doing uh
explicitly and you do this too where you
say here's how to think about that guys
or high performing leaders tell their
team here's how we should be thinking
about ourselves here's how we should be
thinking about the competition here's
how we think about the future of the
company they're saying it they're
explicit more often here's how to think
I mean the the what is it the seventh
most read book in the history of the
world
is Think and Grow Rich crazy it became
that way because he taught people how to
think about money
we have to tell our audience how to
think about things
the second thing they're doing is
they're challenging people
and they're challenging the specific way
if you listen to great oratories a Great
speaker
the pros the one I know I'm like oh this
person studied speech before is they
challenge the audience in three ways
they challenge audiences character
then they challenge the audience's
connections their relationships then
they challenge the audience's
contributions what they're giving
you hit all three of those the audience
is like I have to listen to her I have
to listen to him because not only are
they shaping how I should be thinking
because maybe I was thinking wrong but
now they're pushing me because you know
it's just like a great coach the
greatest coaches they're not just saying
throw the ball better they're like Louis
you're a better man than that come on
man they're saying look you're treating
your team like crap they're look look
you're not contributing the team here
that's a different challenge than just
throw the ball faster or catch the you
know so I studied that from them but
those are the primary things and the
third thing of course is role modeling
you know standing I mean if I'm to bring
the joy guy or I'm the owner of the
struggle guy or I'm the high performance
guy and I'm off my game
um
people are gonna know that yeah
so that's I'm always trying to role
model what I do which is hard when
you're talking about high performance
because everyone thinks well don't you
have a bad day I'm like dude
I I have bad moments I would say bad
days because yeah I don't want to go to
bed and feel like the day was bad um
but at the same time I think that's why
they're developing influence High
performers are not dissatisfied it's
drivers
they're not they're happy High
performers are happier than their peers
we all believe that to get the top it's
going to be lonely at the top and we all
believe you have to grind and kill
yourself to get there yeah and that's
completely wrong and the data proves
that worldwide which is I think just
overcoming a lot of people's biases
about how you work today because right
now
especially today like you know grind on
social media is so popular or hustle or
hustle and by the way none of the top 15
of high performers worldwide identify
with those words they literally don't we
asked them we did a whole keyword
analysis Yep this is actually pretty
cool and high performers explicitly say
these These are three driving feelings
if we said there was a high performance
State it's it's driven from these three
things number one full engagement yes
number two Joy yes
yes and number three confidence yeah
that's what they relate with okay that's
where it's coming from it's a joyous
Journey not a dissatisfied one and this
I had this conversation in the book
um because uh a kind of maybe frame it
this way each of these chapters opens
with a vignette of somebody I worked
with or a situation that I was in that
demonstrated high performance in this
particular situation I'm walking on a
stage thousands of people
after a very famous musician was out
there and was telling the audience that
that person's secret to success remember
thousands of people yes their secret to
that person their whole speech their
secret to success was never settle
never settle nothing is enough never
settle and never be satisfied never be
satisfied always demand more and I'm
like Oh my second slide which is gonna
be on jumbotrons in like 80 Point text
was strive satisfied I'm like oh I'm
gonna have to dispel this for all these
thousands of people I was totally
freaked out yeah and but what I had to
explain to people was not only the data
but it's this uh if you're never
satisfied
I mean what is it true that life is
precious
if it's true that life is precious and
you could be gone tomorrow do you really
want to think you know what I just never
felt fulfilled
I never allowed myself to have a moment
of credit I never allowed myself to have
a moment of peace I never allowed myself
to look at that and say good job
that's not the way to live life right I
think just at a spiritual level it's a
bad move and this book doesn't really go
into a lot of that it's more about the
science and the hard stuff
but I think it's really important that
people realize your job is to strive
satisfied and if you strive satisfied
more often
you will be more of a high performer and
if you never give yourself credit you're
always beating up on yourself you're
always thinking that's not perfect
enough
then what's going to happen dissatisfied
people burn out and they quit
more often than satisfied Strivers so
take joy in the moment
engage with what you're doing allow
credit and satisfaction and joy to come
in you can always be improving of course
but be proving be improving joyfully big
development growth point for people is
determining how do I really want to
treat people
when they don't agree with me
or when they're hating on me or when
they're discounting me or they're being
mean to me or we're in a fight
because I think some of those are the
greatest growth areas of our life at the
end of our lives
if we have a moment of cognition we're
going to lay there in bed
and we're going to ask questions about
our life to evaluate whether or not we
were happy with it
and what I've always suggested to people
is
maybe don't pretend you're living your
purpose unless you know
the questions you're going to ask at the
end of your life how do you evaluate it
because otherwise you're kind of living
randomly but when you know oh I'm going
to value my life this way at the very
end now every day you can wake up with
intention now every day you get to wake
up with purpose which is why I love the
name of your show because that's my
thing too it's like this this deep
connection to some type of purpose so
that at the end of our life we're happy
there's no regrets there there's no
sadness there's no oh my gosh why was I
this way or why did I wait to do that
and I my unique story is that I got that
gift at 19
years old people should want to have a
high level of joy and happiness in their
life yeah but they cannot they cannot
wait for it I will say you know the
power plant doesn't have energy
it generates energy I mean technically
it transforms energy from one medium to
another and we can do the same thing you
know you don't have happiness you have
to generate the happiness you don't have
joy you generate joy and when you learn
to take control of your power and your
energy in that way that might become so
much more fulfilling and so much more
fun and it doesn't become fake or forced
because you know it's fake and forced
this all day yeah that's not your
natural state yeah I mean and here's how
you know take a person you know I just
got back from a big vacation with my
lady and and we were down on the beach
and and through you take any person
put him on a beach for a while and
they're not like your natural state is
like this is beautiful this is great
there's awe there's inspiration there's
joy there tap back into that and you'll
be more of a high performer when you get
the life is really short and you felt
that before but either by you were
threatened or you've had someone near
dear near and dear die but when you have
that real Essence in you that says life
is short have reverence for it live it
that's a really big thing I got that at
19 and I learned specifically that if we
have a moment of cognition before the
end of our life we tend to ask questions
to evaluate if we're happy
so if I have any impact in the world
it's going to come from that experience
where
I learned that the ultimate lesson is
determine what the questions you're
going to ask at the end of your life are
going to be
find out those questions what will you
ask at the end of your life to evaluate
your life
so that you would know if you were happy
with your life like figure out those
questions
and then live each day
intentionally so you're happy with the
answers at the end for me the answer is
the questions I had were did I live
which I hadn't I'd been living my life
I've been thinking about taking my life
did I love
no my heart was broken
and I put up all these walls to keep out
other people and I would say you know
sometimes the walls we put up to keep up
the bad guys prevent the good guys from
getting in and suddenly in our own
self-protection we block out the very
thing we want which is connection
and I learned that I would ask did I
matter
you know 22 years ago
on a dark Caribbean night I'm standing
on the crumpled hood of a car
Bleeding Out
my friend
when I just wrecked a car he's screaming
at top of his lungs he's bleeding we
don't freaking live and I'm standing on
the hood this car
looking down all this blood and I'm in
Terror
and I just remember looking down the
hood and just thinking
did I even matter
you know
and I hated the answer at that time in
life
because a 19 year old kid I didn't know
about impact Theory
for real I didn't know to think about
that you some you know young kids
sometimes they don't know to think about
that I didn't know to think about
Legacy meaning
did I matter I didn't think I did
but the good news is I'm a good learner
and I felt like I got a second chance
from God that night and I learned
that it was really important for me to
figure out how do I live and how do I
love and how do I matter in such a way
that if I face my death again I'll know
I've earned the second chance
and so what I want to tell people and
the impact I want is I just want people
to know know your questions Man live
intentionally and earn the life that
you've been given because This Moment's
a blessing so earn this moment and live
intentionally demonstrate courage
and I think all personal development
people of course you know but they
actually High performers do demonstrate
courage like we can measure it from peer
feedback we can measure it from their
self-assessments we can measure it from
we have this thing called the high
performance indicator assessment you
take it you get scored on all six habits
it's free on the internet
um on the interwebs
um but this one's peaked when we did the
research and I didn't know it and it is
high performers are more willing to
share their ideas
their thoughts their feelings what they
need what they want
and they do it more consistently than
their peers even when there's risk or
uncertainty
um you do a great job I know you have
the book's coming out for you talk about
men and being vulnerable
that's demonstrating courage that's yeah
you know when you're not conditioned
that way or you're not used to that you
know that it might not seem like a big
deal but it it is yeah you know
um when you talk about me doing this
interview that was like it might not
seem like demonstrating courage to go on
Lewis house but it is because I admire
you and I also I'm not used to sharing a
lot you know I'm usually let the work
speak for itself yeah so I had to like
okay I need to share you know be willing
to share this in different unique ways
but I think for most people it's
when you're in your last meeting
did you share for your ideas and fight
for them
do you share for yourself you share your
ideas and fight for them
when you wanted to post that video and
you were scared to death because people
are going to make fun of you did you do
it
and when you wanted to tell your spouse
that you're not getting what you need
did you say it
because all those are demonstrating
courage it's not just you know
the courage we think you're pulling
someone out the river or something and
that's part of it and we talk about the
different kinds of courage in the book
human brain has this incredible capacity
for guilt
and most people unconsciously let that
roll over them and kick their butt and
make a horrible life I love guilt guilt
is a tool guilt is a weapon guilt does
not have to be a bad thing it's not like
I perpetuate but I'm like I love that I
feel bad when I don't do a good job
most people hate that about themselves I
love that feeling like I didn't do a
good job there next time I will
so some people
guilt is discouragement
other people it's a signal for learning
to me guilt is a signal for learning it
is the body and the Brain the spirit
knowing what is Right knowing what is
wrong knowing what's great knowing
what's mediocre and saying hey it's a
little better now if it's translated
into a negative impulse then some people
call it guilt but I'm like I'm totally
cool without you know I think it's good
that we feel bad
when we do something that is below our
standard or that's not right because
that impulse to go I want to do that
better stage one was I was honest that I
was a hot mess
like I came back from the accident I'm
like I'm a mess I've been depressed I
was going to kill myself
I'm sad my grades suck my friends are
kind of like losers uh you know not in a
judgmental way to them but in how I
wanted to feel they made me feel bad
about myself and that's why I think a
loser isn't what they've accomplished
it's how they make other people feel two
different things they made me feel bad
and I thought I I don't have it together
and that began my great and long term
committed search to studying psychology
because I'm like why do I think so dumb
why do I feel so bad about myself how do
you overcome you know depression how do
I deal with this sadness
why do I still have so much hatred in my
heart about something that happened so
long ago like just all this like people
say forgiveness how do you do that Oprah
had oprah.com
and I thought how could we to have your
name dot com
now
I sought this kid out so I went to
brendan.com and this guy he had his
resume up there
and that's all he had was a resume so I
emailed the guy and I'm like hey man I
really love to own this website
um could I buy it from you he goes no
it's my name I'm like dang it
and he says uh no you know I got my mom
she's got you know an email we have an
email associated with the domain right
all the stuff I said oh man
all right
ever so I said in my calendar every six
months for six years whoa
my calendar would go off and I'd email
them again
email me again email them again email it
took six years on my sixth year he said
you know what yeah you know I I'd be
interested in that conversation sold it
so I got brandon.com I'm really happy
about that really thrilled that stupid
story but I was like yes
determination found this quote um that
said you know the journey to Greatness
often begins the moment
that challenge and contribution become
more important than comfort and ease oh
that's a good one yeah that's really
good and so we have to challenge
ourselves but the Habit here the social
habit
is develop influence and you develop
influence teach me how to think role
model away and then make sure that you
are challenging people in those three
years challenge their character you got
to do that delicately the book teaches
you how make sure you challenge
relationships because that's so
important and challenge people's what
they're giving and if you do that
strategically enough you know part of
your message in greatness is challenging
people
to follow their dreams you say it all
the time it's one reason I love your
show you're constantly challenging
people to follow their dreams and you're
not just like hey follow your dreams
like hey do this I want to learn to be
confident
I want to learn how to communicate well
and I want to learn to have great
relationships
so I studied those things really
intensely and I just tried them I tried
them and I just I literally I was so
good about making little goal sheets
and trying it and that was the year I
also began my monthly goals so on the
first day of every month to this day I
write a personal goal and a professional
goal every day I look out on the way out
I put on the door I'd walk out and be
patient no matter what my other goals or
objectives were that was like the
defining personal theme so I created
monthly challenge themes for 23 years
you know patients have come up a lot of
times
it's like Joy has come up a lot of time
yes you know uh uh staying centered has
come up a lot of times it's not like I
have ever achieved I've no one achieves
personal development agreed or purpose
it is like
an intention and a dedication
and so that's where it started and by
studying all that
it gave me the edge I really believe
when you are a student of life
especially in Psychology and philosophy
you get the edge because when people are
having problems you can see perspective
around it
and once you have perspective you got
super powers because most people are
trapped in their problems I'm extremely
grateful for the patience and love of my
family in this particular project it
took me away more than anything else I'm
actually really grateful that I've
gotten to know you better and getting
this to be the first like in-depth
conversation with it yeah it's fun
because I think that you're very
talented at holding a space for people
your team too about holding a space for
people just be like
this is me this is what I you know about
yeah um and then I would also
you know I'm always grateful for the God
for the second chance I got
from the standing on the car like I got
it
like
knowing that each day you get up and you
it's not
you know self-help psychobabble it's
like knowing that life is limited and
you get a second chance every morning of
like showing the world more of Who You
Are
you know breathing
um taking that walk with your love just
having that every day that kind of new
beginning I feel that in my career I'm
sharing that with you now and by the
time this comes out you know I'll have a
new show out the Brendan show I've never
done that before as a new opportunity
I'm grateful for the new opportunities I
think right now you and I have the
ability to share our messages farther
and wider than we've ever had before I'm
super grateful that we're alive like
right now at this time on the planet
when I think our messages really need to
be heard when we're you know surrounded
sometimes by a culture Society politics
is so negative to to to to have a
platform to share something good right
now I'm so grateful for that the number
one issue with being productive isn't
that you people usually don't know what
to do with the day it's that they look
at it with Dread and they accept that
feeling and they stop
like I don't wanna so they stop even
though
even though if they looked past the
immediate Dreadful activity and looked
into the future about the benefits it
would give them
if they could reconnect with that they
could push through
it'd say when we get in the short term
just automatic feelings automatic
emotions that come up those things when
they're not monitored consciously and
sometimes they're not overridden by a
higher calling a higher ambition a
higher ambition to serve a higher
Mission than what ends up happening is
we go ah
I'll do it tomorrow
I'll skip this one and you know I'll get
the work out in tomorrow and then
workout comes tomorrow I'll get it in
next Friday and then it doesn't come in
next Friday and then
I'll get the work in the work doesn't
happen and we keep telling ourselves
these stories I'll do it when I feel
like it but I hope if one thing you've
learned here is the power plant doesn't
have energy it
you need to generate the energy in which
you need to Excel and serve in this
world number one
[Music]
is my friend hat which is so important
uh this is where when I'm having a bad
day I always say okay
oh if I was coaching my absolute dearest
best friend in the world who just went
through the same day what would I
suggest that they do next
not how would I change your life not
some big high fluent stuff like what
would I suggest that person they do like
literally next
in that situation they're in would it be
you know what you really need to call
your mom you know what you you need to
call that person apologize you know what
you need to send that email you know
what you need to do is take this but
what would I tell my absolute best most
adored friend to do as their very next
step not the whole plan just what's one
thing I would tell my absolute best
dearest friend I asked myself this
question probably two three times a week
right because I'll get frustrated by
something something'll piss me off or
I'll be bummed that something crashed
and burned I'll be like okay what would
I if my best friend just went through
that exact same thing what would I say
they should do first and of course once
I think of what they should do first
then the next step comes and the next
step in the next step meaning kind of
coach and advise yourself from a third
party standpoint I know you probably
know you should do that but here's the
way that I make it stick
I write the letter
this means I sit down with a blank piece
of paper and I write the letter to
myself from the best friend's
perspective dear Brendan you're really
ugly and stupid but you're my best
friend so buddy here's what I recommend
you do about the situation that you're
in here's how I think you should think
about it here's what I recommend that
you should do
and I literally write the letter to
myself from the perspective of my best
friend does that make sense that's what
I call putting on my friend hat and I
write the letter dear Brendan and
sometimes it's just I write it it's
super short it's on a little note card I
write like 10 sentences other times man
I gotta dig deep and that thing becomes
like a four-page letter to myself you
know and we know from psychology is
specifically dealing with therapy and
Trauma that if you will write yourself a
letter it does significantly change your
emotional well-being and writing it from
this perspective as a friend has I have
found made my letters much more
compassionate much more thoughtful much
more positive so I just put my friend
hat on I write myself a little letter
dude if you're angry free all the time
you gotta change how you look at the
world yes there's a lot in the news that
can piss you off yes there's a lot going
on that causes outrage all day long on
Twitter or social media somewhere but if
that's your sole Focus no wonder you're
upset all the time lots of people are
angry right now because of the news or
something chaotic or terrible or
something they don't agree with is
happening in the world but that's not
new
there's always chaos there's always
turmoil there's always bad things happen
in the world but if that's your focus no
wonder you're having that anxiety and
that frustration and that anger all the
time you got to change both your focus
and how you're reacting to things when
you do see it so first let's work on
your focus you know our as much as
you're angry all the time are you also
noticing the beauty of this world I mean
the odds that you're even alive and
having your breath is something to
connect to every single morning to have
reverence for your life in the morning
to wake up you know one of my late
mentors was Wayne Dyer an amazing
amazing teacher and he always talked
about how he woke up he rolled over he
put his feet on the ground and he said
thank you thank you thank you he was
grateful for his day and he began that
way and I think so many people right now
they kind of roll up in bed and they're
like and they grab their freaking phone
and they start going through the news on
social media and what are they queuing
immediately I'm cueing stress chaos
turmoil clickables you know it's like
clickbait click click clickbait no
wonder you're frustrated you're
activating your brain immediately right
off the beginning of the day in all the
turmoil of the world put the dang phone
down get up and think about what you're
grateful for about what you want to
achieve and give and serve and create
that day about who needs you to be on
your A game that day so you can focus on
that instead of like this in bed that
will change how you start your day and
then listen a lot of people who are
angry all the time they're also in
Outrage all the time because they're
focusing on the problem all the time and
they're bemoaning the problem they're
calling out the problem complaining
about the problem judging criticizing
getting upset all the time a ton of
people who stay in anger all the time
are failing to be solution based
that's what they're doing right they're
just anger anger problem problem outrage
outrage outrage but listen when you
become a solution-based person you say
okay I actually want to do something
about this problem and you start taking
positive steps to at least address it or
to participate suddenly that anger goes
into a new fire and that fire is called
enthusiasm it is easy to switch anger
into enthusiasm when you become solution
based as a mindset when you say okay I
don't like this let me do something let
me let me call somebody let me take this
action let me write that letter let me
send that email let me get my friends
together let's go protest let's go get
involved let's participate because
participation turns anger often into
enthusiasm people say Brennan I'm scared
to start my dream I'm like you're not
scared to start your dream you're
embarrassed to be seen starting small
big difference it's not about the dream
that's freaking you out it's about how
you're gonna feel Chasing the Dream It's
about how you're going to be received
Chasing the Dream It's about how you
fear at night it won't turn out the way
you wanted it's not about the dream it's
about how you're processing how it will
feel Chasing the Dream and once you
figure that out you see that you can
rewire yourself you can teach yourself
to think differently about the journey
and the process because look you know no
matter how small you start
something that matters
start something that brings your life
back you know it starts something that
makes your heart feel full start
something that does scare you allow that
fear allow that worry allow that anxiety
a little bit because that's just saying
you're growing you're learning you're
changing you're getting going but let's
be very clear most people what they're
really scared about is being embarrassed
well I don't know if I quit my job and I
start this thing one of my co-workers
think when I do that I don't know if I
start this what are my friends gonna say
when they see me playing small and not
doing big things because every big
project starts with small little tasks
that don't look sexy oh what's what's
everyone think about me that I chose
this route when the other thing was over
here and that was a better choice what
people are scared about is being
rejected or more being embarrassed I
tell people all the time don't be
embarrassed to start small I I think
about when I started doing videos you
know it was we're 200 million video
views now we I mean tell you what when I
started I was okay with the fact that it
was like 10 people watching my videos
you know nine of them was my mom on a
different browsers probably hit and
refresh to make me feel better about
myself you know like I accepted the fact
that starting small was part of the game
instead of bemoaning that I honored that
process I said that is part of it being
small in a big pond with big fish is
part of the game and only until you keep
playing keep moving keep building do you
ever become one of the big fish you have
to be okay with being small and so if
you start your Channel or you start your
thing and only 100 people watch it hey
that's a hundred people who heard your
message that's a hundred people who you
help that's 100 people who you change
your mindset for that's a hundred people
who let you do your own thing and watch
and even if they were haters at least
you started penetrating their mind get
in the game never be embarrassed about
starting small or Scrappy or crappy
because that's part of the journey it's
supposed to be that way so don't fear it
acknowledge that's part of it I'm gonna
honor that let's go I was a
maybe 24 25 year old man and I was a
member of Kiwanis and if you guys didn't
know Kiwanis was is a it's kind of like
rotary or Lions Club
um it's a it's a a it's a non-profit
organization that's dedicated towards
service in in the community and I was in
Kiwanis and I was the youngest one hands
down like in in the room we get together
every single month on a Tuesday and we
have lunch and we'd have a speaker in
and then we talk about a volunteer
project we were going to do that month
and that was kind of how it went in
Kiwanis for me and so I but in my room I
was 24 25 in the room every Tuesday when
we got together everyone else was older
I mean they were like 50s and 60s and
70s older when I was 25 I was the
youngest person in the room every single
time and
I remember I was having a particularly
a challenging time because I was
thinking about quitting my job but I was
scared because I didn't I hadn't saved
any money
um I didn't know exactly what I wanted
to do I just knew that I I knew that the
job wasn't the thing at the time
but I didn't know what it was and so I
was scared to make the leap and I was
just I was just kind of struggling with
some existential stuff because you know
I'd been four or five years I hadn't had
a girlfriend and it was just frustrating
I was like dating but I wasn't able I
just wasn't making real connections on
when I was dating and I was just unhappy
in that part of my life I didn't know
what I was doing my career I didn't have
a significant relationship I was like oh
man I'm just kind of I didn't feel good
and so I was having to really down day
on that particular Tuesday and I went in
and I was sitting next to this guy and
he was one of the Just One of the
awesome kiwanians that who was there and
he was
um I think he was probably 59 60 years
old he was in banking
um very successful wealthy guy happy hap
just he was like a happy-go-lucky
Grandpa type you know just a good dude
and I'm just kind of listing off to him
all these things that suck you know and
he says what are you doing about it and
I said well you know I you know and he
says why I bet and he said I bet I know
what's going on he's you're going home
you're probably watching too much TV
drinking too much beer and sitting alone
too often or you're going out and not
having any fun and we're just talking my
mode was yeah I kind of I go inside so I
kind of pull away from people when I'm
unhappy and so I was like yeah I kind of
pull away and I'm in my house and he
says why I know how to solve a problem
I said oh what is it he goes buy tickets
buy tickets what do you buy tickets he
goes I want you to open up the paper
remember the papers so he said I want
you to open up the paper and he goes I
want you to see what's going on in your
town and I want you to buy tickets to
whatever's coming up the next seven
weekends
is it is there a symphony coming to town
buy tickets is there a ballet buy
tickets is there a uh an art museum buy
tickets is there he said is there a
concert buy tickets
and I said what do you mean it's buy
tickets I want you to buy one two three
four tickets and I want you to take your
friends and I just want you to go I want
you to buy tickets and I want you to go
and I'm like what hell does this have to
do with anything I'm even talking about
he goes just buy the tickets and come
back next month tell me about the
tickets and I'm like no and he literally
pulls out his wallet and I'll never
forget he sets down three 100 dollar
bills and he goes buy the tickets here's
the money and I'm like what are you even
I was literally so frustrated it's a
long story short I'll try to keep it
shorter but so I bought tickets I got
like a symphony ticket I uh got it there
was like a dance troupe in town or
something weird uh there's a Dave
Matthews concert
and what else is there's one other thing
I can't remember what it was uh shoot
there's something about the tickets I
went with one or two or three friends
and
with them and the second I remember even
I remember
the opening act for the Dave Matthews
Band started and I was like
got it
got it
because sometimes when you're down and
out
you got to get out and about
and so I was down and out and he got me
out and about and then with your friends
and you're socializing and it's in a new
environment and things are happening and
my mind just started turning on again I
started getting all these ideas and
these dreams that I don't know where
they were they weren't in my room they
weren't in my bed these ideas and dreams
they weren't happening in my journal the
the the ideas and dreams they weren't
happening in my my daily planner it was
like I was stuck there so he moved me
over here have you ever been like at a
ballet or a symphony in Orchestra and
you're just sitting there and all of a
sudden you feel amazing
like the music hits you this idea comes
in and you walk out and you feel amazing
have you ever gone to a Broadway show
you went in and you were frustrated and
freaked out because all the horrible New
York traffic and all of a sudden you
laugh your ass off and you leave the
Broadway show and you feel like a
million dollars and now no problem is
gonna slow you down
that's buy tickets
buy tickets to seminar buy tickets to
the event buy tickets to the art museum
the ballet buy tickets and I mean if
you're down and out and your life sucks
right now go buy tickets for the next
four weeks and I promise you're gonna be
like damn buy tickets that changed my
life
changed my life too and I've learned
ever since then like if I'm down and out
it's like buy tickets
if you want another amazing Brendan
burchard video check it out right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there